good evening ladles and jelly spoons
very nice to see you all and oh my
goodness don't you look mighty fine
especially of course Willy Holliday who
frankly and I'd like to lick like a
lolly like a human lolly yes yes
shut up Willy it's not about you stop
fooling pulling focus with your long
glistening come hither legs and let me
concentrate please on this other
slightly less exciting person but it's
my duty to introduce tonight I am here
apparently inexplicably to celebrate the
woman I know as Jennifer
yes yes Jennifer Doudna / lives upon a
hill she hates this song by the way what
you do in Jennifer my love Jennifer
juniper Jennifer juniper uh uh yes her
why exactly she is being rewarded for
her continued bad behavior and
relentless showing off is utterly beyond
me so I asked glamour to give me some
kind of indication as to why in the name
of holy tits
she should be chosen above many others
so much more deserving some of whom are
in this very room tonight standing right
in front of you
and here is what glamour sent me she's a
comedy icon with an International Emmy a
BAFTA fellowship and a Writers Guild
Award to prove it yeah and over the last
thirty years she has appeared in over 30
TV shows has she really exaggerating and
alongside her longtime comedy partner
insert name of other woman
has become one of the most beloved
comedy duo's in British TV history all
right I'm buying it a little bit more
now she is responsible for creating two
of the most seminal characters in sitcom
history as supposedly in the guise of
Edie and pottsy who this summer make a
triumphant return on the silver screen
and the huge big fuck-off movie version
of absolutely fabulous so she is an
inspiration to a whole new generation of
young female comics really including Amy
Schumer really rebel Wilson and Lena
Dunham to name a few this is a pack of
insufferable lies but hey home showbiz
is a fickle old [ __ ] who loves you one
minute and then sleeps with Russell
Brand behind your back
and brings you a mammoth yeast infection
so it only remains for me to say that
unbelievably Glamour's outstanding
contribution award is presented to a
woman it's been my job to work with for
far too many years the absolutely
flatulent miss fatty Saunders
go stand behind me you [ __ ] [ __ ] come
here thank you so much
I have see can't believe it that's
amazing and to be honest Joe I would
have come to the party anyway it's
amazing because you get most
extraordinary goodie bag if you win an
award honestly you should try harder if
you ever won one because it's like huge
just like a [ __ ] lorry kelleners if I
get through the creams I've got now at
my house I may live to be 300 I think my
corpse may be dead but my skin [ __ ] so
many serums but I'd like to thank this
person here that's not sexual yes it is
no it's not yeah it's my hopes thank you
cause my my lovely good friend here dawn
clad gets me every time
dawn France yeah thank you honesty when
I wouldn't be here if it wasn't for you
you've been my inspiration you're the
most amazing woman in the world and to
be honest I know I'll be honest now
really I was in the car on the way here
with Dawn and she says if you don't say
that I will kick you up the pant and
those are our accent no seriously
where's our Axl I'm not joking there's
my heart actual words from the moment
I wasn't supposed to say that that's
true just our stop it Goosen me and I
just want to say if I have made I hope
I'm gonna get serious and I move away
here at me shut up the sick if I have
made Marshall come back if I've made an
outstanding contribution to anything I
hope it's to the promotion of female
friendships because seriously I was
thinking about it and I was thinking
with the work that I've done with you
know I wouldn't be here to be honest I
actually wouldn't be if it wasn't for
dawn she discovered me and brought me
along in her coattails to here and and
with Joanna and absolutely fabulous it's
about female friendships and about
empowerment for women and the necessity
not to have a normal heterosexual
relationship to define you so I Lee I
hope if I contribute to anything is that
and I would like to dedicate this award
actually to someone who passed away this
year Victoria Wood
I think for me she was a great friend to
us and she helped us and it's a great
loss and I dedicated to her so thank you
so much thank you